for men  we have babies until the end of time for  you  from 35 it gets risky it does  so you can say ah you know  if i'm single today which i'm not  but if i was i'm i  i've got a goal down the spectrum  because i don't want that risk why am i  going to have a risk or you're 35 you're  gonna have certain baggage  because we all got baggage so but  you know by then it's other people's  stuff that's coming into my relationship  and guess what i don't want it  so by 35 you need to be  more or less  in your stride with someone even if it's  not marriage  even if it's not marriage you shouldn't  be on the market at 35  so i'm not saying you have to be married  but i'm saying you need to be clearly  off the market